hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website com2 they're gonna be going over
a really cool aggressive defense from
black against the Italian game that I
see every now and then the Italian game
Pawnee for Pawnee five and your opponent
immediately playing a bishop here to see
for now it's more common to first get
your nice involved into the game Knight
to f3 Knight to c3 but Bishop to c4 is
pretty common trying to control the
center of the board with both the pawn
and the bishop and the Calabrese counter
game it is pawn to f5 very very
aggressive move from black so this is
what we're gonna be going over today
this is my opinion probably to be the
most in-depth video that you'll ever
find on the Calabrese counter game it's
hopefully you'll learn a lot you can try
it out and definitely get some wins
under your belt against the Italian game
now while there are tons and tons of
variations we're gonna be looking at the
main ones that you may see and some of
the more common moves that people play
if they are white now the first line
that you may see is the bishop take here
on g8 now while it's not always the most
common for white to give up his light
square bishop in exchange for a Knights
early on he may do it for two reasons
one is because after black takes here on
g8 black can no longer castle on the
King side usually when you play pawn
here to f5 giving up material signifying
that hey you're giving up material
you're gonna cast on the King side
somewhat of a Kings gambit as black to
control this long semi open file with
your rook black no longer has that King
side safety no more since he can't
castle and also white can immediately
bring his Queen down here to h5 check
and start to put a lot of pressure on
black because this is the most common
move after Queen here to h5 attack we're
gonna go over that line just so you can
kind of see what that looks like like
pretty much has to play pawn here to g6
stopping that that Queen from attacking
the Queen will now come down and capture
here on h7 and then the rooks gonna play
rook to d7 now it kind of looks messed
up from blacks point of view it looks
like he's just getting destroyed
dominated but really he's kind of taking
this Queen out of the game and his Kings
pretty safe here on a Yates yes he
hasn't castled yes he's probably not
gonna Castle for a while sin
he still has to somehow develop the rest
of his pieces on this Queen side but
this Queens not really going to be doing
a whole lot more harm and white really
hasn't developed any of his other pieces
doesn't really have a strong presence in
the center of the board besides this
epon right here and so there's a few
ways that white may continue he could
play Queen here to h8 he could play
Queen here to h6 if he decides to play
Queen here to h8 then black can play
Queen here to g5 and this is a pretty
devastating move as far as White's
concerned because again white really
hasn't played to many of his pieces yes
he has played his Queen over here but
it's just moving along this h-file it's
not doing a whole heck of a lot black on
the other hand has a pretty aggressive
setup and this rook here in Bishop
actually hold a pretty strong fort and
really keep white at bay now the Queen
here on g5 is attacking this pawn here
on g2 so white really needs to defend
that he could play pawn here to g3
stopping it you could play Queen here to
h3 two different options if you plays
pawn here to g3 then Black's gonna take
with this pawn here on e4 completely
blowing up the stern of the board black
now has a huge advantage in the center
it's really tough to see how why it's
gonna continue he doesn't have his light
squared bishop to fianchetto here to g2
he can't play the natural move of knight
here to f3 trying to control the center
of the board he could try something he
would really like to play pawn here to
d3 with the discovered attack but the
Queen could just take her on c1 that's
gonna be a pretty bad move he could try
the Knight to c3 here but then Queen to
f5 continues with the pressure it's
still gonna be very very difficult for
White's to really find any game because
again black is just dominating even
though he hasn't Castle now instead of
the Queen coming here or instead of the
pawn coming to a g3 again the other move
we talked about is the Queen back here
to h3 black can play a little bit more
patiently he can play knight here to c6
again developing his pieces trying to
control the center of the board from
here if now we see Knight to f3 it's
hacking the Queen the Queen can always
come back here to e7 he's not in a huge
rush to real
attack right away he feels pretty
confident and safe if the pawn now takes
here on f5 knowing that the queen is
protecting it right here then we could
play pawn pushing forward to e4
attacking this Knight the Knights forced
to move it doesn't really have any great
squares it could come to h4 if it wanted
to again everywhere else is pretty bad
and then we have a pawn here to d5 again
blacks now controlling the center of the
board Black has his other piece now
Bishop here on c8 attacking this
material definitely gonna be good for
for black white could try something
pretty creative he could play Knight
takes here on g6 after our rook takes
now the Queen can come down to h5
pinning down the rook and this pawn
attacking as well but the bishop can
take here on f5 all of a sudden black
has complete control this urn of the
board his rook is actually nicely
defended it's gonna be very difficult
for this Queen alone to attack the King
the King's pretty safe he can actually
castle on the Queen side now if he
wanted to black is in complete control
white hasn't moved any of his pieces
back here all the moot pieces that he
has moved all of a sudden are no longer
in the board and whites gonna have to
really to have some sort of game plan to
get back in this because black in this
particular case is dominating now
instead of the Queen coming to age 8 he
doesn't have to play that he could play
Queen here to h6 trying to maintain some
of that pressure over here also allowing
him to come back if he ever does need to
retreat black can just continue trying
to control the center of the board with
Knight here to c6 and this can be pretty
devastating because it allows him to
play this Knight to d4 which can be
pretty devastating
you may see your opponent played Knight
to c3 trying to develop some of his
pieces on the board this is gonna be
completely fine because now Knight to d4
is that dagger attacking the square here
on c2
forking the king and the rook why it's
really gonna have a difficult time to
deal with that instead you could see
Knight here to f3 this is even worse for
white because after the pawn takes
forcing this knight to move next move
from black is to bring his knight here
to d4 now attacking this we're here on
c2 as well so that's gonna be bad as
well
white could try to be super aggressive
and play pawn here to d4 attack in the
center opening up the door for his
Bishop to come to g5 attacking the Queen
this can be pretty troublesome but black
could continue with the same game plan
of bling aggressive play pawn here to d5
trying to break up the center of the
board after Bishop to g5 attacking the
Queen here on d8 Queen here to d6 is
completely safe it's also defending this
square here on g6 allows this Queen to
come outside the pawn chain is hard to
attack if he wants to there's just not a
lot of great squares that y can really
find here he could if he takes with his
pawn here he may not know how to take in
this but to your case so there's there's
no so many variations
after the pawn takes Knight takes on d4
black has a huge advantage right here
this Knights really tough to deal with
if instead we see pawn take here on e5
then we can have the Queen come here to
be for attacking this pawn here on b2
and check this is very bad for white as
well or we could even see just the pawn
take here on f5 and then the knight
takes here on d4 still attacking this as
well so so many different ways for white
to just fall into traps because he just
doesn't know how to attack now from an
actual game which was pretty interesting
is after the knight came here to c3 why
try to play a little bit more passive he
played pawn here to the d3 and then we
have pawn here to d5 trying to break up
the center then the Queen came back here
to III trying to get his Queen back
involved into the game back on h6 is
just not doing a whole heck of a lot of
anything
now the knight came here to d4 again
attacking the square here on c2 white
did somewhat lose a move because he
played Queen here to e3 now all of a
sudden he has to move it to defend the
square here on c2 so he brought his
queen back here to d2 and then pawn
takes pawn takes this opens up this file
right here so black decides to go ahead
and swing his rook over here to d7
recognizing that once this Knight moves
he'll have a discovered attack on this
Queen so if you were to play Knight here
to f3 check and allowing him to attack
this Queen right
the Queen's gonna move out of the way
Queen 2c3 trying to control the surname
of the board but still get out of the
way but then black was able to find
Bishop here too before pinning down the
Queen the Queen is forced to do
something he decides to take and then
Knight taking here on c2 forking this
Queen why it was forced to resign all
that to say your prototype might not
play exactly like that but the point of
the Calabrese counter gambit is to put
your opponent in a ton of really really
difficult positions and there's so many
different ways that he can fall into a
trap or fall behind or even lose the
game very quickly I really really like
all the attacking lines that black has
in this opening now we spent a lot of
time so far looking at what happens that
the bishop takes the night here on g8
there's a very real possibility your
opponent may not do that what one thing
he may do is decide to go ahead and take
this pawn here on f5 that's gonna be
fine Black's gonna continue with Knight
here to f6 very similar to kind of you
play the King's game it for whites kind
of on the reverse side right here later
black will look to push forward with his
pawn control the center of the board and
open up the board for his LightSquared
Bishop sits retake this pawn here on f5
now as far as what white could do one of
the moves would be Knight to f3 then we
could see pushing forward with pawn here
to d5 attacking this Bishop if in case
our opponent plays Bishop here to b5
threatening Kat checking our King right
here on EA's pawn to c6 the bishop comes
back here to a4 very important to note
if you see this in this particular case
you've already stretched forward you're
a little thin on the King side as far as
defense do not play pawn here to b5 I
think this is a critical mistake after
Bishop here to b3y can just really let
black overextend himself these pawns
right here are gonna be very difficult
for black to really control all of them
there's so much air right now to go
ahead and get underneath here and attack
this King I really just don't like this
setup for black instead once this Bishop
come back here that's gonna be fine
black can push forward with pawn here to
e4 he really has this long very
structured pawn structure it's all
pointing at the
kingside so more than likely the attacks
gonna be going at the kingside of whites
but this is a much better setup for
black now if the Queen were to come to
e2 so that this pawn couldn't be
captured or this night couldn't be
captured by the pawn then Bishop takes
here on f5 recapturing now both sides
are equal in material but all of a
sudden black is completely dominating
the center of the board this is
definitely gonna be a much better setup
for black if instead the Queen now the
knight comes here to e5 trying to be a
little bit more aggressive than bringing
his Queen out right away then Bishop
here to d6 attacking this Knights the
night could try to get somewhat creative
playing Knight here to g4 knowing that
his queen is protecting it but after
Knight takes in the Queen captures black
and castle on the Kings side all of a
sudden he has his bishop in his rook
attacking this square right here this
rook is controlling the semi open file
Black has a huge advantage he's
completely dominating the center of the
board his bishop pair are completely
dominating white really doesn't have any
of his pieces develop besides his bishop
over here on a4 but even if his bishop
comes to b3 he's not gonna have any sort
of attack so this is definitely gonna be
very very good for black another thing
that you could see instead of the knight
coming here to g4 is pawn to d4 trying
to solidify this Black has a few options
my recommendation is not to take with a
pissant right here I just don't think
it's very good and I can come back here
this kind of opens up this file right
here for white to attack and it kind of
messed up some of the center control
that black had with his central square
pawn of efore instead black can continue
controlling the center with his pawns
and play knight here to d7 this is gonna
be completely fine now sort of forcing
the hand of white to do something on the
board this is gonna be good for black as
well if we back up a few moves after
Knight to f6 instead of playing this
knight here to f3 another move that we
could see is pawn here to d4 striking
the center of the board we're just gonna
go ahead and take that material that's
gonna be completely okay with us
now if honor if our opponent takes with
Queen
to d4 we're now gonna just push forward
with pawn here to d5 forcing this bishop
to move that's gonna be fine we can now
get our dark square Bishop involved into
the game castle on the Kings side we're
now opening up the door with the
discovered attack with our Bishop here
on f5 so a lot of different options for
black in this particular case now if the
Queen doesn't take because he doesn't
have to you can play Queen here to e2
forcing our move this is gonna be good
for us because we're trying to develop
our Bishop to castle on the King side so
this is gonna be fine
Knight here to f3 we could first push
forward with pawn here to d5 threatening
for this Bishop to move first and then
castle on the King side that's gonna be
fine for black as well now if we come
back to the beginning of the Italian
attack and then we play this pawn here
to f5 you could see an aggressive Queen
here to h5 from White's now usually you
don't want to bring your queen involved
into the action unless you have a real
strong reason to it's just gonna be very
very easy for black to stop this pawn
here to g6 supports it right away the
Queen can't take you to materials kind
of forced to go back really doesn't want
to play Queen here to e2 or d1 I mean I
guess he could but it it's just not it's
kind of a wasted move he could try Queen
here to f3 to try to be somewhat
aggressive control the center of the
board but this just kind of blocks off
some of his development Knight to f3 can
no longer come into the game this is
just not not as good as it could
potentially be Knight to f6 continuing
the same development for black as he
wants to Knight here to c3 because his
knight can't come into the action Knight
here to see that c6 also threatening
this Knight here to d4 next so a lot of
different ways for black to attack this
I would I wouldn't be worried too much
if the Queen ever came down there to h5
because he just doesn't have a strong
attack the next option that you may see
is pawn here to d4 striking the zoom the
board putting us to the test it's very
important to understand how you should
capture in this particular case you need
to capture with your epod just like this
now there's a few ways for whites to
respond now he could take our F pawn
that's gonna be fine we're gonna play
Knight here to f6 kind of forcing our
opponent's hand
now he has a few options he could play
Knight to f3 attacking this we're gonna
play pawn here to d5 really it doesn't
matter what he plays he could take with
his queen we're playing this pawn here
to d5 getting ready to get our bishop
involved into the game castle on the
Kings side same game plan that we've
seen before if instead of taking he
could play Knight to f3 right away
attacking this but this is gonna be a
lot worse just because the pawn can take
forcing the knight to move it if he does
take now that's not gonna be the worst
thing Knight takes here on d4 Knight to
f6 defending this square right here now
if we see Knight to c3 very interesting
move to attack the square now black
really needs to play pawn here to c6
getting ready to set up with pawn here
to d5 he wants to play pawning it to d5
right away but he just doesn't have the
material to kind of hold down the fort
so first pawn here to c6 and then push
forward with pawn here to d5 is
definitely enough way for black to
continue now does have the other option
I have seen after the pawn takes the
bishop can now come to g8 he may not
want to do it early on but may decide to
do it now black is forced to play this
rook takes here you could not have the
Queen coming to the action trying to
control this urn of the board Knight to
c6 attacking forcing this Queen to move
somewhere there's no great squares for
this Queen to go to obviously major
mistakes would be Queen here to see
three because Bishop here to be for
pinning it down the Queen's going to
fall that we obviously know it's going
to be very very bad we could see Queen
here to c4 trying to control the center
of the board still attacking this rook
right here on g8 but just pawn to d5
kind of stops it yes our opponent can
just play pawn here to d5 but black has
a nice little subtle move of Knight here
to b5 this not only opens up the door
but also you know we have this bishop
here defending it and now we have the
two attackers that we want on this
square right here white can't try
something funny
like a Knight to c3 because then we can
easily just come in and fork this rook
over here so pretty nice move from black
if it comes to that another move that
you may see is pawn here to d3 pretty
pretty passive way to do it sometimes
players play pretty passively if they
don't know what you're doing
they just don't want to fall in any
traps Black's gonna continue with Knight
to f6 control the sooner the board
develop his pieces Knight here to f3
knight c6 Castle and then Bishop here to
c5 this is a pretty natural way next
could be pawn here to d6 if we want to
opening up the door we can castle on the
Queen side we can castle on the King
side so we still have some options
depending on where our ponents go and
how we want to control the center of the
board now if we come back another move
that you may see is Knight to c3
attacking this is probably one of the
safer options for whites I really hope
my opponent doesn't play this because I
want us to get pretty crazy on the board
just because I like wild and crazy
tactics so Knight to f3 gonna be the
same more than likely if he's playing
the same option of Knight to c3 he's
probably gonna continue with a d3 we
have Knight to c6 Knight f3 some of the
similar stuff we saw before we could
take now if we wanted to laughter it
takes Bishop here to c5 we could even
play Bishop here to B for pinning down
this Knight because we have that option
now so a few different ways to attack
this another option that you could see
we're not gonna go over too much about
it just because it is a different
opening is Knight here to f3 this gets
into the Latvian gambit which is a
different opening one of my favorite
openings but now blacks just going to
take with his pawn here on e4 if you
want to go further down this rabbit
trail it usually starts out instead of
the bishop coming here to c4 first it's
instead the Knights coming here to f3
and then pawn here to f5 but it usually
has bishop here to c4 after that this is
the Latvian game it's so again we're not
going to do a video on this but just in
case you see this and you want to learn
about how that variation works out you
can definitely watch the video that I
made on the lab in game it so hopefully
guys enjoyed this rather in-depth video
on the Calabrese counter gamut I think
it's one of the more comprehensive of
videos or even study guides out there on
the counter game it I've used it a lot
and I really liked it so hopefully you
learn something you can try it out if
your opponent ever does play the Italian
game but thanks for watching let me know
what you guys think and I'll see on the
next video